so I think there can be a role for
inflation whether or not it's true I'm
not sure 10% right but nevertheless it
does serve eight an obvious purpose that
we might like to take advantage of in
understanding why we started from
someplace very special and got the
universe we see well now that we've
cleared all that up I doubt that there
are any questions because it was all
very clear but on the off chance that
there are any anyone and I think with
the microphone because we will bring a
microphone to you there's a there's a
lady here please and then there's
someone at the back there I'll dot
around up and please please make it a
question and not a short lecture because
we've pushed for time well let me just
say I mean there are two concepts and
make sure they're completely different
then one of them is called dark energy
which is meant to be explaining this
exponential expansion that we see the
other is dark matter which explains why
the rotation of galaxies isn't
constrained by just the method we see
there is other matter now the dark
energy I think they're both very bad
names because first of all dark energy
is neither energy in the ordinary sense
of the world nor is it dark because it's
it's invisible so I think it's it's not
I mean dust you see you see these dust
rings and galaxies that's what those are
dark things but dark energy is not dark
in sake it's a I think it's simply the
term that Einstein introduced in 1917
for admittedly completely the wrong
reason but it was right that this term
in his equations the only thing you can
do without wrecking them is this thing
called the cosmological constant and it
seems to be there it was taken seriously
about cosmologists even if not by
Einstein after he introduced the idea so
that's the dark energy of course it
means why is it they've got the
and all that sort of stuff that matter
is a different kettle of fish that
matter is something it's a material
which is out there and it is invisible
now I should explain that this crazy
theory I was just talking about earlier
which I considered not so crazy but
that's most anyway but there's an e on
the far before ours the thing which
constrains the universe if you look at
the equations and I'm not going to give
them to you here but if you look at the
equations you see there has to be
something a dark material as or an
invisible material which dominates the
material in the universe it has to be
there all the equations don't make sense
and this is what I claimed up and then
that matter how do you get right way
around dark matter is so it's got to be
there for this theory to make sense
dark energy all of the cosmological
constant certainly has to be there for
the theory to make sense so if you want
reasons the other way around if you like
the theory doesn't work unless you have
both of them now the dark matter exactly
what is it well in this theory it's
nothing that particle physicists would
think of the particles of dark matter
would be about what's called the Planck
mass that is something like the mass of
a fleas I know it's it's 10 to the minus
5 grams grams and that is not so small
not so big I mean it's it's big for
particle particle physics point of view
because it's hugely more massive than a
proton so particle physics don't
consider it but that's what the theory
predicts you've got something like that
perfectly consistent with observations
has to be there because the theory is
says it's got to be there that's the
best answer I can give you a quick
question what if it's there why haven't
we seen it rotational II seen there was
here we've detected its influence in the
room yeah absolutely but probably it's
in the room yeah own interest
gravitation you don't see the air either
no no I'm willing to take it on faith of
this here I'm feeling the need for some
actually there was a there's a question
back there yes
you hand up again whoever it was yes
thank you um so I just was wondering if
you could tell me a little bit more
about the motivation the cosmological
motivation for the multiverse and like
where the other universes would be
because I know like in every FG anism
they kind of occupy the same space and
just don't interact okay so in terms of
motivation I I think as a scientist
really our only motivation is try to
understand the universe and the world
around us so if there is one universe or
or if there is a multiverse whatever we
find that's the one who we find and
report there is no other motivation
except that one and we looked and that's
what we found it's until now physics has
been concerned in fact physics wasn't
even a field until a century ago and and
physics has been concerned with small
scales intermediate scales their skills
once you you have a good understanding
of what's inside your universe at all
possible scales and of course you come
head-on with the big question the
biggest question of all at least for our
universe which is what was there before
our universe came came into being and
and that kind of theoretical motivation
to try and understand always one step
further has come in tandem with progress
in in observational physics we can see
further now we can that that's why I
said before we don't have a choice
whether our universe at the beginning or
not we know it at the beginning we can
see it looking far away in space we're
looking back in time so we can
practically run the the cosmic story of
our universe backwards and see that that
it it started small and and it grew big
and where are they these of universes
here is the main philosophical reason on
why the multiverse research really took
off only on the last 10 15 years or so
he's not that people didn't conceive of
of the possibility before in fact the
first one was a bit curious the atomists
but the the the general belief in the
physics community was that even if there
is a multiverse you can't apply the
scientific method to it you can't see it
with direct observation by definition
nothing can travel further then you can
send the light signal and and receive it
beyond the edge of our universe and the
only way we can see is by sending and
receiving light signals so if I can't
receive a signal beyond four four
structures or whatever there is beyond
the horizon of our local universe it
means that we cannot test what's beyond
the horizon of our universe so that
seems to imply that these theories are
not scientific if you can test them then
they are not scientific and and that's
part of the work I did about twelve
years ago we saw that that's not correct
you can test them not by direct
observation indeed you can't receive a
light signal but but you can use first
off a coherent theoretical mathematical
structure that that makes predictions at
all scale so if they are found to be
correct and then one that's one hopeful
direction but there is another tool that
you can use and that is quantum
entanglement so if you think of our
local universe and whatever else there
is beyond our universe in in the cosmos
in in in the work that I did in in in my
theory all all of these structures were
once wave functions of the universe so
they were want them entangled with one
another and if if quantum mechanics is
is if quantum theory is valid then
entanglement is always present and the
information is never lost meaning that
even though eventually all these
branches decoupled from one another and
created universes in a similar story to
to how our universe was created that
that information about their early
entanglement about their origins is
still there it's imprinted in our sky
and and that's where cosmologies is one
of the most
citing fields in physics because
whatever we see around us today in this
big boring nearly empty universe
whatever we see it's actually a snapshot
of the infant universe that cosmic
microwave background it's that the
younger generation don't want no but but
the older ones remember the TV set when
when you couldn't find the channel the
old TV sets you'd get that boozes on the
screen that that was the cosmic
microwave background that you are
observing but that cosmic microwave
background today a 2.7 Kelvin is nothing
more than just a rescaled version a
stretched version of the radiation that
was created early on in the life of the
universe so it contains all that wealth
of information and and so in in short in
at least in my work and I think there
was a lot of work being done after that
in in other variations of the multiverse
once you have this coherent picture and
you have a tool quantum entanglement
that you can calculate how that
signature changed the the Cosmic
Microwave Background of your sky and
what that should look like the day
redshifted today in our present universe
then you can make a series of
predictions and and that's where we got
lucky one of the things we did in 2005
was for example there were seven but the
most dramatic one was the existence of a
giant void in the sky and at the time of
course everything thought we were crazy
to to talk of a 10-degree area in the
sky being empty of structure but only a
few weeks ago that was confirmed as a
five seeker discovery by the Planck
satellite experiment so there is one
example where you cannot prove okay um
sadly I'm afraid we are fundamentally
out of time and we can't run it
backwards or get it from any other
universe I'm afraid and so really all it
remains is for me to ask you to join me
in thanking our panelists
I can also just tell you before you all
head off that the next debate here is
mind matter and mechanisms oh no that's
in the other one isn't it because we
moved yes sorry all three will be going
to the bookshop where you can impress
them with more deep and philosophical
questions that they don't want you to
ask Roger is going to be talking about
beauty in our world and physics truth
and beauty of for Lara's going to be in
conversation over lunch open platform
and Shawn's going to be back here back
in the ring at 3:00 thank you very much
you did you know that the Institute of
Arts and ideas also has a podcast
philosophy for our times brings you the
biggest ideas from the leading thinkers
around the world every week search for
philosophy for our times and subscribe
today on your favorite podcast platform
SoundCloud or iTunes to make sure you
never miss an episode